so let's say you wanted to know where
the center of mass was between this 2
kilogram mass and the 6 kilogram mass
now they're separated by 10 centimeters
so it's somewhere in between them and we
know it's going to be closer to the
larger mass because the center of mass
is always closer to the larger mass but
exactly where is it going to be we'd
need a formula to figure this out and
the formula for the center of mass looks
like this
it says the location of the center of
mass that's what this is this x cm is
just the location of the center of mass
it's the position of the center of mass
is going to equal you take all the
masses that you're trying to find the
center of mass between
you take all those masses times their
positions and you add up all of these m
times x's until you've accounted for
every single m times x there is in your
system and then you just divide by all
of the masses added together and what
you get out of this is the location of
the center of mass so let's use this
let's use this for this example problem
right here let's see what we get we'll
have that the center of mass the
position of the center of mass is going
to be equal to
all right so i'll take m1 which you
could take either one as m1 but i
already colored this one red so we'll
just say the two kilogram mass is m1 and
we're gonna have to multiply by x1 the
position of mass one and at this point
you might be confused you might be like
the position i don't know what the
position is there's no coordinate system
up here well you get to pick so you get
to decide where you're measuring these
positions from and wherever you decide
to measure them from will also be the
point where the center of mass is
measured from in other words you get to
choose where x equals zero let's just
say for the sake of argument the
left-hand side over here is x equals
zero let's say right here is x equals
zero on our number line and then it goes
this way it's positive this way so if
this is x equals zero halfway would be x
equals five and then over here would be
x equals ten we're free to choose that
in fact it's kind of cool because if
this is x equals zero the position of
mass one is 0 meters so it's going to be
this term is just going to go away which
is okay we're going to have to add to
that m2 which is 6 kilograms times the
position of m2 again we can choose
whatever point we want but we have to be
consistent we already chose this as x
equals zero for mass one so that still
has to be x equals zero for mass two
that means this has to be ten
centimeters now and then those are our
only two masses so we stop there and we
just divide by all the masses added
together which is going to be 2
kilograms for m1 plus 6 kilograms for m2
and what we get out of this is 2 times 0
0 plus 6 times 10 is 60 kilograms
centimeters divided by two plus six is
going to be eight kilograms which gives
us
7.5 centimeters so it's going to be 7.5
centimeters from the point we called x
equals zero which is right here that's
the location of the center of mass so in
other words if you connected these two
spheres by a rod a light rod and you put
a pivot right here they would balance at
that point right there and just to show
you you might be like wait we can choose
any point as x equals zero won't we get
a different number you will so let's say
you did this so instead of instead of
picking that as x equals zero let's say
we pick this side as x equals zero let's
say we say
x equals zero is this six kilogram
masses position what are we going to get
then we'll get the location of the
center of mass for this calculation is
going to be well we'll have two
kilograms but now the location of the
two kilogram mass is not zero
it's going to be if this is 0 and we're
considering this way is positive it's
going to be negative 10 centimeters
because it's 10 centimeters to the left
so this is going to be negative 10
centimeters plus
6 kilograms times now the location of
the 6 kilogram mass is zero using this
convention and we divide by both of the
masses added up so that's still two
kilograms plus six kilograms and what
are we going to get we're going to get 2
times negative 10 plus 6 times zero well
that's just zero so there's going to be
negative 20 kilograms centimeters
divided by 8 kilograms gives us negative
2.5 centimeters so you might be worried
you might be like what we got a
different answer the location can't
change based on where we're measuring
from and it didn't change it's still in
the exact same position because now this
negative 2.5 centimeters is measured
relative to this x equals zero so what's
negative 2.5 centimeters from here it's
2.5 centimeters to the left which lo and
behold is exactly at the same point
since this was 7.5 and this is negative
2.5 and the whole thing is 10
centimeters it gives you the exact same
location for the center of mass it has
to it can't change based on whether
you're calling this point zero or this
point zero but you have to be careful
and consistent with your choice any
choice will work but you have to be
consistent with it and you have to know
at the end where is this answer measured
from otherwise you won't be able to
interpret what this number means at the
end so recapping you can use the center
of mass formula to find the exact
location of the center of mass between a
system of objects you add all the masses
times their positions and divide by the
total mass the position can be measured
relative to any point you call x equals
zero and the number you get out of that
calculation will be the distance from x
equals zero to the center of mass of
that system